WOJTEK KALICINSKI: Have you
ever had to join a new team
and jump into coding
quickly, but found
that setting up all the
tools and external libraries
is taking forever?
I know the last thing I need
when approaching a deadline
is to spend time trying
to make my project build.
That's why Android Studio
includes a simple to use
and powerful build system based
on Gradle that makes you more
productive from the get-go.
It favors convention
over configuration,
giving you [INAUDIBLE]
defaults to get you started,
while still allowing for more
advanced features like better
library management, built-in
multi-APK support, and more.
Let me show you a few examples.
Your build configuration and
all your projects' dependencies
are kept in Gradle build files
using an intuitive declarative
syntax.
These files are
the single source
of truth about your project.
What this means is essentially
that any changes you make here
will be automatically
reflected in the IDE,
so features like code
completion, for example,
are always up to date with
your project's configuration.
Even better, the same
build files can also
be used by Gradle
on the command line
and in your continuous
integration server,
ensuring consistent
and reproducible builds
in any environment.
When you've spent years
with Android Eclipse,
it is a big task to
learn a new build system.
That's why when importing
a project from Eclipse,
Android Studio automatically
creates Gradle files for you,
and even identifies
commonly used libraries
and brings them in
as dependencies.
The basic configuration for you
app like the application ID,
minimum and target SDK,
and versioning information
are now declared in
the default config
section of the build file.
You can also see any
local and remote libraries
that your project depends on
in the dependency section.
In the case when
Android Studio fails
to recognize your dependency
when importing a project,
or if you're just looking
to add a new library,
you can easily find out the
right package name and version
to put here by using
the Maven search dialog.
If you're still
confused, and just want
to get started quickly,
you can get some examples
of useful libraries like the
F [? Compact ?] and others
on the Gradle.please website.
Another challenge when creating
or using third party libraries
was that there used
to be no efficient way
to distribute additional
Android-specific
resources along with code.
You either had to move
directories around
or be limited to
a JAR file, which
can only contain Java classes.
With Gradle, we've
introduced support
for the Android
Archive Format, AAR,
for short, which lets
you publish or attach
to your project a self-contained
library with all its resources,
assets, and even
manifest entries.
But there is so much more in
Android Studio than just better
library management.
Have you ever had to build
multiple versions of your app
and deal with code duplication
or other workarounds?
With the flexibility
of Gradle, you
can now create
different variants
of the same application
from a single project.
You get to debug and
release build types
by default, and together
with product flavors
that you set up, they create
what we call build variants.
Build types and
product flavors are
a very powerful and
customizable concept.
For example, you can define
separate sign-in configurations
for each build
type, or if you want
to upload a free and paid
version of your app to the Play
Store, you could override the
application ID previously known
as Package Name
for both flavors.
Easy.
Moreover, each type,
flavor, and variant
can contain its own bits
of code and resources,
which will be merged
with the main code base.
It's even possible to specify
additional permissions
and components or
override manifest settings
that you only want to
have in certain flavors
but not in others.
You can use this mechanism
together with multi-APK support
in the Play Store to create and
publish device-specific APKs
for different screen densities,
CPU types, or API levels.
The important wins here are
a better developer experience
for you and smaller download
sizes for your users.
When working with
variants, Android Studio
will only show files relevant to
the currently selected version
in the Project Overview.
To change which version of
your app you want to work on,
use the Build Variants pane.
You can also check out all
the automatically generated
build tasks for each of your
variants in the Gradle sidebar.
Just use the
Assemble task if you
want to build all possible
configurations of your app.
As you can see,
with Android Studio,
we finally have
a modern powerful
build system that takes the pain
out of managing your projects.
We've just scratched the surface
of what's possible with Gradle
in this video, so if you
have any other questions,
join our community on Google+.
See you in the next Android
Studio videos very soon.